anfang juli verkündet das russische
verteidigungsministerium eine operative
pause im donna summer dieser
vermeintliche pause zieht eine neue
erschreckende kriegstaktik nach sich
denn zeitgleich nimmt der kreml wieder
ukrainische städte im landesinneren ins
visier befeuert ohne unterlass die
ballungszentren mit raketen mit
marschflugkörpern
es sind menschen verachtende angriffe
und genau mit denen will putin zeigen
dass niemand in der ukraine sicher ist
und eines wird dabei auch ganz deutlich
auch vor zivilisten macht er keinen halt
jetzt trifft es wieder die metropole
rötlich der region don was einen
raketeneinschlag eine heftige explosion
im zentrum der stadt drei menschen
sterben etliche werden verletzt unser
auslandsreporter björn spritze ist
beinahe zufällig genau zu dem zeitpunkt
des angriffs nhk hier sind seine
eindrücke
die blutlache am boden sind noch frisch
dazwischen menschliche knochen splittern
das zentrum dieses wohngebietes ins
latifah im norden der stadt katif ein
ort der verwüstung
nur wenige augenblicke zuvor schlägt
hier eine russische artillerie rakete
ein drei menschen sterben darunter ein
13-jähriger junge sein vater kniet in
verzweiflung stundenlang beten neben
seiner leiche
die arglosen opfer warten an einer
bushaltestelle
die wucht der explosion zerfetzt ihre
körper beschädigt mehrere gebäude wir
sind hier in hf der zweitgrößten stadt
mussten der ukraine wo es heute morgen
einen russischen raketen angriffe
gegeben hat der drei menschen getötet
hat darunter einen 13 jährigen jungen es
gab mehrere verletzte die sind
mittlerweile schon auf dem weg ins
krankenhaus sind werden notversorgt und
hinter mir sehen wir bereits die
aufräumarbeiten das ist auch etwas was
sehr typisch ist für die ukraine
mittlerweile dass nur wenige stunden
nach einem solchen angriff nach seinem
solchen einschlag einer rakete war es in
diesem fall sofort die anwohner
herauskommen die scherben zusammenkehren
und das leben im prinzip weiter geht in
den vergangenen monaten wird der ort
immer wieder schwer bombardiert um
möglichst viele zivilisten dabei zu
töten setzt die russische armee
vorzugsweise streumunition ein
doch zuletzt nahm das dauerbombardement
ab jetzt da die russischen truppen aus
den vororten der stadt zurückgedrängt
wurden cat das leben nach und nach
zurück zu einer neuen normalität
doch wie dieser hinterhältige raketen
terror beweist es ist eine trügerische
stille
putins kaltblütiges signal
niemand in der ukraine ist sicher
wir treffen den 61 jährigen andre
als er die explosion hörte er zum
anschlagsort um zu helfen
ich habe bis gerade eben noch hier in
diesem gebäude gearbeitet
als ich rauskam solch einen toten am
boden aber das material
dann sah ich den jungen er atmete noch
ein polizist leistete erste hilfe
der junge war blutüberströmt schwer
verletzt
aber noch bevor die rettungskräfte
gekommen sind dass er dann verstorben
seine schwester wurde ebenfalls schwer
verletzt
sie wurde ins krankenhaus gebracht
er steht noch immer unter dem eindruck
des geschehens
ich komme aus russland
lebe seit 20 jahren in der ukraine
ich habe familie auch in deutschland
aber ich will hier nicht weg in
die leute hier brauchen